[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
Toyota one of the world's most
recognizable brands they're known to be
affordable and reliable in fact I had a
friend that didn't put any engine oil in
his old Corolla for years he just said
he forgot and the car still ran fine and
then there was that time that the
original Top Gear crew tried to destroy
a Toyota Hilux they ran into a tree
drowned it dropped a caravan on it hit
it with a wrecking ball burnt it lifted
it onto the top of a building which then
got demolished and it was still running
after all of this
according to statistics from the
manufacturer as many as 80% of their car
sold in the last 20 years are still on
the road so it's clear that Toyota's a
well-built and they're a common sight in
most places around the world but how did
the company start and what's the story
behind it how big are they and what are
some lesser-known facts about Toyota
it's been a while since I've done a
video on the how big series so let's
take a look it all begins in the most
humble way a son who found the
inspiration to make his mother's life a
little bit easier the story starts with
Sakichi Toyoda who was born in 1867 in
the city of casaya growing up Sakichi
was inspired by a self-help book in the
book was a description of an inventor
who created motorised textile machinery
while coming home one day after working
for his father's carpentry business
Toyota had noticed how hard his mother
worked to weave textiles and in that
moment he decided that a self-powered
machine would make her life easier
despite opposition from his father he
decided to dedicate all of his time to
the project in 1898 he submitted his
patent of the Toyota power loom a type
of textile machine it used a
one-horsepower oil motor and would be
the first power loom in Japan it quickly
to reclaim and attention for its ability
to reliably produce high-quality cotton
after catching the eye of a prominent
businessman in May of 1986 Toyota
founded the Toyota loom company as a
joint-stock venture but it wasn't all
smooth sailing in 1910 he was forced to
resign after Japan had a major recession
to blow off some steam Sakichi took a
trip to the US and Europe he was amazed
at the level of technological
advancement but it was the automobile in
particular that caught his attention
inspired he decided to return to Japan
and start a new company with his son
Kitty ro although the new company was
named Toyota spinning and weaving
Sakichi still had his mind on the
automobile
in 1929 he sold the rights to his
powered weaving machine for 1 million
yen and gave the money to his son only
on the one condition that he would use
the money to create Japan's own
automobile in the beginning Gojira was
unsure but after it shipped to the US to
observe the manufacturing process he was
convinced that it was possible around
the same time the Japanese government
was offering incentives for
entrepreneurs to create a Japanese car
Gojira took this as a sign and began
diversifying away from the textile
industry and into the automotive
industry in 1932 to prototype cars were
released this fast adaptation to change
proved to be a decision that would alter
the course of history in the following
year the newly formed Toyota automatic
loom works dedicated all the efforts to
produce cars the first production cars
rolled out in 1935 and the division
became its own company Toyota Motor
Company in 1937 the aim of Toyota was to
be cheaper than the other cars imported
by Ford or General Motors the first cars
were an instant success in Japan and
Toyota was on its way
the vehicles were originally sold under
the brand name Toyota with a D this was
after the name of the company's founder
but later of course this was changed to
Toyota the word Toyota means fertile
rice paddies not something suitable for
a car manufacturer in hindsight
continuing to the momentum in the late
1930s
kotero set up a research lab his
reasoning was very insightful
he stated quote I want to gradually get
rid of this attitude of taking the
easiest path by taking someone else's
hard work we have relied on the west
until now if we want to truly make
Japan's industry independent we have to
cultivate that drive end quote
after expanding to multiple production
plants in the 1930s the events of World
War two in the 1940s almost destroyed
the company causing cachero to resign
the next few years will be a bumpy road
but in a strange twist it was the Korean
war that saved her the company was in
the verge of bankruptcy
but in the first few months of the
Korean War the United States ordered
more than 5,000 vehicles from Toyota
reviving the company in the 1950s some
managers noticed that American workers
were 9 times more productive as the
Japanese they discovered that the issue
wasn't with the people but the process
throughout this decade the company
focused their efforts on increasing
productivity by streamlining their
process to boost efficiency with
productivity beginning to increase in
1955 they shifted their sights to the
global market upon a visit to the US the
world's biggest market at the time a
Toyota executive noted that there were
many small European cars alongside the
larger US ones he saw a problem they
were too expensive as a reaction to this
Toyota built an affordable car and
pushed it into the US market it was
called the toyopet crown the company's
excitement was at a fever pitch this was
going to be their big break as it turns
out it was a complete disaster only 300
cars were sold the main reason was that
they had misunderstood American roads
for Japanese roads the crown was fine
but when it was put on the US highways
it would overheat lose power and drink
way too much fuel Toyota had to go back
to the drawing board the result was
Toyota's total quality control a
complete process that included
everything from the staffs level of
enjoyment to a drive for constant
improvement after this they exported
globally the export strategy was
something called Genki when bhutesu it
means go to the source and get the facts
to make the right decision
after much research of external markets
their cars began to succeed overseas
1966 would see the release of the toyota
corolla one of the most popular cars of
all time
[Music]
[Music]
the oil crisis of the 1970s with further
propel the need for smaller cars that
were more efficient on fuel they were
selling cars like crazy with my next
Dave disaster the oil embargo came along
and couldn't sell big cars it also
affect people that had bought big cars
for bringing them back leave them on the
lots of here I don't want it I won't be
able to buy gas for it but when the
American manufacturers decided to go
towards smaller cars cost-cutting meant
that their quality just couldn't match
that of Toyota
from this time on Toyota was unstoppable
with hits like the Camry in 1982 and the
acclaimed Supra and mr2 and of course
the Prius in 1989 a company would move
up market with their sub brand Lexus
over the decades the lineup continued to
grow now there's almost a hundred
different models of Toyota cars globally
today tota is one of the most
recognizable brands their cars they're
everywhere you look on the road so how
big are they in 2015 Toyota was the
number one car manufacturer but since
then they've lost the top spot to VW
Toyota's production topped out at ten
point two million cars last year
slightly less than VW's ten point three
million coming in at third was General
Motors with nine point eight million
cars produced so a three-way battle
between Germany Japan and the United
States how about that last year Toyota
made 248 billion dollars in revenue and
twenty point three billion dollars in
profit they have a total of four hundred
and nineteen billion dollars worth of
assets for comparison Volkswagen made
one hundred twenty three billion dollars
in revenue last year and 2.2 billion
dollars in profit
General Motors 166 billion in revenue
and nine billion in profit Toyota is the
biggest company in Japan by market
capitalization they're almost twice as
big as the second largest company which
is Softbank Toyota owns Daihatsu Lexus
hi know they have a sixteen point seven
percent stake in Subaru a six percent
stake in Isuzu most surprisingly up
until 2016 toda had a ten
stake in Tesla but they sold it as the
companies began to become competitors
the Japanese firm also owns cure Hawkeye
group which has another 334 companies
under its name they also own red
entertainment which is a video game
developer in addition to cars tirta is
part owner of Mitsubishi Aircraft Corp
which will be creating a regional jet
within the next year the company has
manufacturing plants in 27 countries
including Russia Turkey Poland Brazil
France Canada the UK and the u.s. they
have 349 thousand employees Toyota is
the ninth largest company on earth in
terms of revenue they also take part in
philanthropic efforts in education
conservation safety and disaster relief
for example the Toyota USA Foundation
supports education in science technology
engineering and mathematics the Food
Bank of New York City uses Toyota to
improve their processes and operations
Toyota has also been making humanoid
robots as early as 2004 the company also
has banking financing and Leasing
branches ok so we're almost at the end
of the video but before we finish things
off let's take a look at the six
surprising facts about Toyota number 6
from 1966 Toyota has been manufacturing
and selling a Corolla every 37 seconds
on average but if that's not enough now
they're selling one every 15 seconds at
44 million sales if you lined up all the
Corollas sold back-to-back it will make
a line around the earth five times these
Corollas have collectively driven 50
round trips between the Earth and Sun
the Corolla has been the best-selling
nameplate since 1997
number five the company has the highest
number of global patents in the auto
industry at over 1500 annually they
spend 9 billion US dollars in R&D and at
times they've put as much as 1 million
dollars every hour just into research
if you remember this goes back almost a
hundred years to catch Erie Toyota's
philosophy some fruits of this research
is a new solid-state battery that could
be in cars by 2020 and a hydrogen fuel
cell car called the Toyota mihari
finally after 20 years of research there
is a hydrogen fuel cell car now number 4
Toyota is one of the most global brands
while other big brands like coca-cola
and McDonald's may top out at being in
about a hundred countries Thota is in
over 170 countries number three there
Automation pioneers the company has been
using robots in their plants since the
1970s and today Toyota uses their robots
to help with medicinal and nursing
support along with the assistance of
those with limited mobility number two
the Prius is the best-selling hybrid of
all time since 1997 they've sold over 6
million cars number one in 2017 fortune
named Toyota as one of the world's most
of my company's 3 years in a row they've
also won the winning title of number one
vehicle company three years in a row for
those of you wondering Toyota
automatically works still exists today
they're now called Toyota Industries
Corporation and are the world's largest
manufacturer of forklifts Toyota are
also still in the textile industry
creating computerized automatic looms
and sewing machines it's pretty cool
that the company's roots still exist
today
so there you have it from watching his
mother worked too hard and having the
idea to make her life easier all the way
to being one of the largest car
manufacturers the world has ever seen
when you really think about it there's
no way of knowing where a simple spark
of inspiration will take you so next
time you see a tire on the road have a
bit of a think about that anyway thanks
for watching this has been - go go
you've been watching cold fusion if
you've just stumbled across this channel
feel free to subscribe alright so I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]